[Musique]
ce que nous souhaitons avec la création
de cette commission denquête ce n'est
pas pour nous d'être des procureurs mais
c'est de comprendre en fait un certain
mécanisme est de
comprendre les donc les raisons qui
motivent le recours par les pouvoirs
publics de cabinet de conseil privé
parce qu'après tout il s'agit quand même
de l'utilisation d'argent public
c'est quand même un gros sujet et
deuxième gros sujet il peut être aussi
question de notre souveraineté le
recours par l'état des conseils
extérieurs fait souvent mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'objet de
raccourcis simplistes dans le débat
public ma conviction est qu'il faut
l'aborder avec beaucoup de pragmatisme
je le dis aussi sans détour l'état n'est
ni omniscient ni omnipotent vous avez
obtenu un contrat d'un montant de 496
1800 euros
pour je cite
évaluer les évolutions du métier
d'enseignant vous pouvez nous dire à
quoi aboutit cette mission
l'intervention des cabinets de conseil
dans le secteur sanitaire n'est pas
nouvelle elle a toutefois pu susciter
une certaine émotion dans l'opinion
publique lors de la crise sanitaire nous
ne sommes pas là pour minimiser
l'ampleur de la crise sanitaire ni le
travail accompli par l'ensemble des
fonctionnaires pour y faire face à la
demande de la commission d' enquête le
ministère à translink l'ensemble des
livrables des cabinets de conseils
pendant la crise sanitaire et
sincèrement nous vous en remercions
toutefois leur lecture donne quand même
le vertige
car elle les montre une intervention
massive de ces cabinets sur tous les
pans de la crise sanitaire et sur des
missions qui nous semblait relever de
l'administration ce ne sont pas des
livrables pardonnez moi ce sont des
documents internes au ministère qui
relève des équipes du ministère et
auquel mckinsey a participé durant ford
équipe et vous avez parlé de la prise de
décision à aucun moment mckinsey ne m'a
fait prendre une décision en lien avec
la crise sanitaire et où laquelle la
campagne vaccinale nous avons eu
connaissance d'une circulaire du du
premier ministre qui encadrant le
recours au cabinet de conseil je voulais
savoir si vous aviez été consultés en
amont sur cette circulaire ne rompt
compte tenu du rôle effectivement de la
haute autorité
on peut penser que un avis
serait utile
il peut y avoir un intérêt
en matière de réputation etc pour les
cabinets de travail et pro bono pour
l'état très précisément le samedi 14
mars
effectivement moi j'ai eu un appel
à l'époque du cabinet du premier
ministre pour me dire il ya plusieurs
grands cabinets de conseil qui se sont
manifestés pour aider voilà intel intel
si tu veux tu peux les appeler ils sont
à dispo pour faire du pro bono si vous
me demandez quel niveau de sécurité des
cabinets de conseil et quelle est leur
capacité à protéger l'information de
leurs clients je ne sais pas vous répond
et c'est peut-être un problème est ce
que vous considérez que c'est le rôle
d'un cabinet de conseil de formuler des
propositions qui ressemble à un
programme politique et qui sont mises
sur la place publique et ensuite comment
garantir la neutralité de vos
propositions